[Music]
thank you Carl and thank you Kate for
joining us um Carl writes in the
magazine this week as a as part of our
cover piece about the coid inquiry and
about what it's looking at and in
particular what it's not looking at um
it's been in the news a lot this week
because Dominick Cummings and Lee Kane
have impaired in front of the inquiry uh
Kate to to start us off what what have
you made of the inquiry so far I think
one of the big concerns around this
inquiry John wasn't just how long it was
going to take but that there might be a
predetermined set of conclusions that
the inquiry was was trying to seek out
predominantly that lockdown didn't
happened fast enough and that it wasn't
hard enough and I'm afraid to say I
think some of those fears may be coming
to light and and and I don't say that
casually look at what we had when
Professor Ferguson took the stand we had
a very strange set of questions which
insisted that Professor Ferguson hadn't
been a big enough advocate for lockdown
that he hadn't done enough to warn the
government now there are lots of things
that you can level at what he was called
at the time Professor lockdown but the
idea that he wasn't encouraging lockdown
or wasn't making this information clear
to government is just certainly not one
of them indeed he was messaging emailing
number 10 almost acknowledging that that
was a bit above and beyond his Rema but
he wanted to let them know his views on
the situ situation and and how strongly
uh he felt uh about the need for
intervention so this idea that of all
people Professor Ferguson is being asked
why he didn't do enough to Advocate
lockdown I think does suggest that
there's a particular uh set of ideas and
a a very narrow interpretation of the
so-called science which and I Know Carl
gets into in his piece for the magazine
this week uh that they really want to to
advocate for in this inquiry and it's
not obvious to me whatsoever that that
is the right way to be going about this
we we need to be questioning every
assumption that was made we need to be
questioning every bit of policy and law
that was implemented around this whether
or not it yielded the right results not
simply did they do it to Loosely should
it have been harder and should it have
been faster and we should say at this
point Carl as well as writing about the
inquiry for us this week you've also
impaired in front of the inquiry which
was which was last week um when you were
in front of the inquiry did you get the
sense as Kate says there that that the
inquiry was coming from a very
particular ideological bent and the
questions to you were more about
imposing that ideology than than finding
out what what would needed to be found
out so yeah look I think Kate's got it
spot on actually but let let me just
explain what happened is I was asked to
submit written evidence and that written
evidence was about 74 pages about 23,000
words I tried to keep it sub sync
because I could have carried on for
quite some time and in that evidence
there were about 12 issues that were
identified I was going to go to the
inquiry and ask to be uh an oral witness
and present and talk about I actually
thought we was going to go there and
give an a position to start to unpick
some of these issues why is a
mathematical modeling used so much given
its track record of getting it so wrong
why are we using that and actually if
you look at the inquiry it seems to be
saying the modeling is de facto evidence
and not actually looking at the
assumptions that go into it and saying
well actually every prediction in the in
the whole coid pandemic was incorrect
but what happened when it got there was
something that actually concerned me my
evidence was cut short and about 20
minutes before they introduced a load of
new documents and said we're going to
discuss this and we're going to start to
go into your character who you are who
why am I there to make decisions and
influence the issues if you like and
that's largely because of what happened
on the 20 of September when cetra up to
myself and Anders tgnel met with the
prime minister to discuss the issues at
hand and I I I discussed this actually
within the article there are over 200
Sage advisors yet within those advisors
they couldn't find somebody to provide
an alternative Viewpoint or actually
robustly ask questions about the
assumptions and the data we were using
to that point so actually when you look
at the inquiry it's failing to ask the
important question particularly do
lockdowns work should we do lockdowns
next time if so what sort of evidence
should we base them on and particular
what are the widespread harms that occur
when you do a lockdown that actually
need to take into account that would
then give you what happens in health
care is a normal is to take a a basis of
a decision based on the net benefit to
harm ratio and if the Harm's outweigh
the benefits you don't go there h i mean
Carl at the inquiry you kind of asked a
bit about your own credentials and
whether or not you're qualified to speak
about this kind of thing do you think
that's kind of part of part of the
problem mindset perhaps that the the
inquiry wants to sort of label people
into good and bad scientists and decide
which are the good ones we should listen
to well it certainly felt that way
because other Witnesses who've gone
there have been able to lay out the
whole of their credibility but what they
wanted to do was go here's what you
published in 201819 and you didn't
publish on SARS coov V2 by the way and I
go well nobody was publishing on that
but at that moment in time I was bmj
Editor in Chief I totally revamped the
journal and created a new series about
Healthcare decisionmaking it also didn't
go back into my past experience and
particularly say I'm an active clinician
I've actually worked in the past
pandemic looking at swine flu government
appearances it dismissed all that and I
that's the point when you're in a
position like that and you under the
caution effect what happened is I
suddenly realized there was a change of
Direction here this is not feeling as
though I'm here to establish the truth
is more to undermine my credibility and
what happens in that position I think
all you can ever do is try and get out
of there with your reputation intact
because it felt like nobody was
listening and all I was doing was being
under attack and I think what they
really wanted me to do was lose my call
and then use that to dis credit of
certain Viewpoint I think that was
unacceptable there is a real story to be
told and evidence to be brought forward
by what we call the other side but
actually those who want to produce an
evidence-based approach and actually I
was the only witness that's called from
that position despite the fact I think
the public huge sves of the media
understand that's an important
discussion and debate that has to ever
be had okay I think that brings us
nicely on to what happened during the
inquiry this week and in particular the
inquiries focus on bad
language uh abusive statements made by
various people privately inside number
10 and out um why do you think there's
been such that focus by the inquiry on
sort of on name calling rather than
perhaps more substantive issues it's
almost as if John the inquiry thinks
that the news is in the fact that these
rude words were bandied about and that
these messages were sent I'm I'm not
going to repeat most of them I know Carl
had one um directed at him which was
extreme extremely rude uh by Professor
Dame Angela McLean who's now the chief
scientific adviser uh I won't repeat
that one but she also called Rishi sunak
Dr Death in relation to his eat out to
help out policy um and of course this
makes for great politics but in my
opinion the news is not actually these
rude words that were used we can talk
about the tone and and the attitudes
within government sure we talk about
that all the time the real question is
you know put the put the rude words
aside were any of these attacks or
claims Justified what did Eed out to
help out really do uh was questioning
some of that modeling at the time the
right or wrong thing to do my
frustration with this inquiry is that
the focus is on personalities and
individuals that's easy because a lot of
the individuals and personalities
involved are um you know truly
spectacular and it makes for a good
television it makes for a good inquiry
um but if we want to have a better more
robust policy when it comes to pandemics
in the future the question that's been
on my mind and continues to be on my
mind and I haven't had any answers to
yet is were those models and were the
assumptions going into those models
correct you know if we just take one
example Sage was saying that at the
height um of coid you would have 990,000
hospital beds with ventilators needed I
think at the peak it was closer to 2,500
and almost half of the ventilators on
the NHS weren't used I want to know
names aside you know rude comments aside
whether or not um we think that it was
right to question those models whether
we think enough people did question
those models whether with eat out to
help out the right trade-offs were ever
considered between the pandemic and
every other aspect of society and public
life and every other illness that people
were suffering from that was keeping
them away from the NHS that was leading
people to lose their jobs and the rest
of it um we have not gotten into the
details of that instead the explosive
news stories from the perspective of the
inquiry seem to be who called what when
uh and uh yeah it it makes for good
television but frankly it's not I don't
think it's making us any safer for the
future when the next pandemic comes
along let's be clear the language that's
being used is completely unacceptable
and what needs to happen is it needs to
be called out what we think should
happen now is all these diar and all
these WhatsApp messages should just be
published in full and then there should
be a statement across government to say
this is completely unacceptable and
actually there needs to be a changing
culture you just wouldn't accept that in
the workplace so why should we accept it
the head of government the second Point
once you've dismissed with that then we
can get back to the business of
understanding what the lessons should be
learned that's what we're about and
that's what the inquir is about second I
wanted to make a point about Dominick
Cummings and both Neil Ferguson were
asked about why they broke lockdown and
they went into apologetic mode and said
well sorry but the point is that's not
the point
the point that should be looked at to is
with people who broke lockdown and had
parties surely there was a mismatch
between the fear messaging they were
producing and how they were behaving in
the real world so they could not or
believed the messages and the risks that
were being put out to the public because
would you go and break them if there was
a killer virus out there certainly not
and this is the key issue in the in the
inquiry to me is do you need legal
restri restrictions to mandate people to
do things or as in Sweden can you trust
the population to understand the risks
and behave appropriately and therefore
that's where when you look at ICU
capacity and all that somebody should
have brought in and Ferguson did do a
model for Sweden that was incorrect
because you can see that because they
didn't lock down now bringing in the
Swedish data starts to allow you to show
the incorrectness of the modeling
approach because it all breaks down when
you've got a control group like Sweden
why is that not happening because we're
completely distracted by this messaging
of which I assume is going to be more
and more apart from the Scottish inquiry
bit of this inquiry because he seems
they've deleted all their messages which
again is wholly inappropriate because
government should be transparent and a
good example of this is what happens in
the USA because in the USA all of the
devices and all the emails has to be
kept in full and just like Hillary
Clinton she was in deep trouble when she
started to use prime emails so they
shouldn't be performing government
functions in the background and deleting
messages they should be open in the in
the public Arena um Kate on on Carl's
point there about the Sweden comparisons
particularly I mean obviously it's not
entirely conclusive at this stage but it
does look as though Sweden has done
particularly well on excess deaths which
is one of the the better ways of
measuring how countries did in the
pandemic
do you get the sense that the inquiry
has been particularly good at looking at
International comparisons perhaps or do
you think it's it's p too my opic at
this stage and just very much focused on
what was going on inside number 10
rather than looking elsewhere it's very
much focused on what was going on inside
number 10 and look I'm very happy to
keep the government accountable I think
I'm one of the handful of people left in
the UK that is still infuriated every
day by party gate the fact that as Carl
says people were living one way and
instructing and actually sending the
police after people if they dare to do
anything similar so I'm all for keeping
government accountable here but the
wider point about public safety and real
public health is whether or not the
right decisions were made to keep the
largest number of people alive and
healthy and and there's been a lot of
scrutiny for example around one of Boris
Johnson's messages this week it's been
put to Dominic Cummings and Lee Kaine
from the whatsapps where he uses frankly
crass language to talk about Co but
questions whether or not more lockdowns
are necessary given the fact that the
average age of somebody passing away
from coid is above the average life
expectancy age he's asking questions
about NHS capacity again the news story
is that Boris Johnson writes this in a
rather crass way if you break down what
he's asking they are very very
legitimate points we should have been
looking at quality numbers the quality
of life for years lost we should have
been looking at the impact on excess
death deaths not just coid deaths
because we are now in a situation with a
7.6 million waiting list on NHS England
alone where the NHS is truly overwhelmed
where you have people who are very young
finding out that they have developed
cancer you have tragic situations now
because of that very extreme
stay-at-home messaging I think what
countries like Sweden taught us is is
not that people were going to keep going
about their daily lives when we had this
new mystery virus going around but
actually that you don't always need to
bring in the harshest laws that you can
trust people to make cautious good
decisions and that actually that trust
that Sweden put in their public has led
to fewer people dying overall you know
that that is a hugely positive thing and
something that we have to take away for
the next pandemic but unfortunately
comments based on the way that they're
worded and these WhatsApp messages are
being scrutinized for you know very
surface level kinds of language they're
not being scrutinized for the actual
content of it uh which is clearly what
we should be doing and unfortunately
it's just not happening yet and and
finally to finish is off Carl I mean Co
probably won't be the last pandemic that
happens hopefully hopefully nothing like
it in in the immediate future but do you
get the sense after sort of
participating with the inquiry and been
writing for us this week that the
country is any is going to have learned
any of the lessons from the past few
years the next time a pandemic comes
along do you mind if I come in on the
excess death issues you mentioned about
where we are because it's it is crucial
and I I'm sorry to no of course no go
ahead
look as we sit here about just over
three years into the pandemic three and
a half and it's come to an end there are
countries that have done really well in
that period one of them's Denmark they
have no excess death when you look at
their data and it's quite interesting
it's really interesting I've been
looking to them well they have an
amazing social care provision I consider
that actually is worth looking at but
there are countries that have done badly
like Belgium which is generally because
I think they've got an incredibly poor
Care Home sector so it's that issue at
the EXP
looking at the extremes will allow you
to understand what's going on but if we
look at the data say in England and I
want to this is one of the things in in
the real there's about 165,000 excess
deaths over the three and a half years
yeah now importantly if you're look in
hospitals there's about 60,000 excess
deaths but actually if you count the
number of coid deaths is 140,000 so if
you looked at the coid death you just go
oh 140,000 deaths in hospital and then
you quite that to EXs that's a mistake
but there is one area where there's an
EXs death problem which I think reveals
an awful lot that needs to be looked at
and you can look at this on the office
for health and income disparities
Improvement and disparities website it's
great website provides you with the data
and the images in the home there was
108,000 excess deaths of which only
12,800 about 12% were down to co that
can't be an Under reporting because
we're testing every everybody on the
death certificat we're more likely to do
it so the story of this pandemic the
restrictions and everything we've done
is that there's been a huge excess
deaths in our own homes that n nearly
90% of it is not down to coid so if we
were going to learn a lesson we'd start
to break down the data dive into it and
go well what's going on and then the
government would go let's investigate
what's going on and understand the
drivers so we can learn lessons and in
doing so that's how an inquiry would get
to somewhere near the truth but like you
say is it doesn't seem to want to go
there brilliant thank you very much KL
and thank you
[Music]
Kate